[Music]
hey you guys it's sunday yeah how is you
guys weekend
going all right how many people are in
there they're coming around they're
coming in there's none of them yeah i
can't there's nine of them
all right all right they're already
talking about wax on wax off
all right
so we'll uh all right they're all coming
in all right so um the other day uh i s
somebody sent us a steel book i think it
was louie i think it was probably louie
louis he sends nothing but awesome
movies and he tries to send steel books
when he can and uh it sat around here
for a couple months before we got around
to it because there's a bunch of other
stuff in the queue
and um
of course we're i'm fans of the series
and we're we've seen every season of
cobra kai out too
um
but i hadn't seen a steel book uh
blu-ray edition of this and it looks
real good so the quality on it is good
real good
um
we had i think last time i saw this
movie might have been about two three
years ago yeah i remember watching them
i don't remember if we reviewed it
before i kind of felt like we had but i
guess not i think we just watched it i
think we watched the first two or the
first three we watched all three we
maybe did yeah like a couple of years
third one was getting a little rough man
yeah that's right now the third one's
the one where they go to yeah where it
wasn't bad it's just that you could tell
they were they were stretching the
plausibility of this story
and really the tone of it had gotten to
the point where it was almost like cobra
kai which is
kind of ludicrous and
nostalgia but i love cobra kai i think
it's a [ __ ] great series it is yeah
so
the first uh installment in the original
trilogy i'mma call it an original
trilogy i would say that the trilogy is
looking culturally on par
in many ways with star wars
mr miyagi is very much like yoda
and uh like in what's his name it's
looking a lot like uh [ __ ] um
luke skywalker in some way yeah that's
true yeah and uh you know
it's um but seeing it again uh
it's a good movie it's real good it's uh
and now it's got a certain tone to it
all right
and you have to be in your 40s or 50s to
understand that tone really vibe but
although man some of the young people
are really getting into these old tones
because they were yeah they were
optimistic they were stories of yeah i
think and we were talking about this
when we were watching it i said i think
the reason that a lot of
people our age that saw these when we
were kids like still you know have a lot
of fondness for them but also people who
weren't even alive like when these came
out still really kind of like them i
think it's just because
they had like a real like you said like
an optimistic like earnestness to them
like they're cheesy yeah but they're
kind of they're really like well-meaning
yeah and
inspirational like in a way you know
what i mean it's like like i said you
can watch them nowadays and it's like
kind of cheesy and it's ridiculous yeah
but they're not in not in like a wink
wink sort of way no no they're earnest
really yeah uh and they're but they're
not preachy at all
you know they you know they're fighting
their feel-good movies
but they're not they don't really talk
down to you either
and uh but now it's a great movie uh pat
morita [ __ ] knocking it out of the
park i mean he makes this let's be
honest just
would not have really worked without
maria all right and he played mr miyagi
mr miyagi
mr miyagi's he's basically
yoda um but they give a lot of depth to
the character
later on you find out he has a backstory
that was kind of tragic and heroic at
the same time he was kind of a tragic
hero figure where he was uh
he was in he was in the u.s army during
world war ii fighting the germans
and uh but he was from okinawa
and uh got the congressional medal of
honor
and um i think his family was in an
internment camp yeah during all that
and then um later on his uh wife back
and he married in okinawa
uh cutie and she died in childbirth yeah
and he lost it it's like and so
and he and he never really gets over it
and you know there's a damn scene where
um [ __ ] what's what's the [ __ ]
what's the [ __ ] main character's name
again [ __ ] something uh i'm kind of
brand locked daniel danny yeah
daniel daniel yeah daniel [ __ ] finds
him in a moment of his weakness he's
drunk and celebrating the damn
the the uh anniversary the anniversary
of his [ __ ] wife who'd passed away
and he's [ __ ] crying over and reading
the [ __ ] letter and [ __ ] and passed
out on the damn
bed and uh
thinking
danny kind of has a
uh his first kind of like
experience of [ __ ] being able to like
empathize with like uh something greater
than himself you know like this dude you
know this old dude he went through some
[ __ ] it's kind of like his first step
into manhood
that
that this could happen to anybody even
somebody who you really look up to who's
teaching you all this mystical [ __ ] you
know with martial arts even he had a
rough time
you know yeah which is i think that's
kind of cool because it's like at this
point you know him and miyagi were
friends and he was teaching him stuff
but that
him kind of like coming across miyagi in
that like sad like you know vulnerable
moment yeah it really kind of like gave
him a new
appreciation and he really kind of like
grew up i actually really love that
scene
um and then after miyagi like passes out
i love that daniel like before he leaves
he just bows to him and then yeah yeah i
think that's so great yeah that
basically what the lesson there that
that is trying to teach you is that life
is tragic it always is because it all it
always ends
it's just are you going to play the end
you know what are you going to be like
in old age what is going to be like when
you face death
and that goes back to all eastern
philosophy if they're holistic
philosophies
uh influenced a lot by by buddhism and
the four noble truths that always have
to do in the end with accepting your
death
and uh martial arts not only uh
not only you know uh karate but also
things like bushido and things kind of
like uh
uh
gangster and outlaw ways of the [ __ ] of
the east you know kind of like what was
his name musashi who was more of an
outlaw than anything else even he said
that you know the first steps you must
take as a warrior is to re
resolutely accept the inevitability of
your death
and that's what frees you
from that pressure
now just you now have freedom of mo of
motion
freedom of deciding things
uh when you understand
eastern philosophies that you see a lot
of that theme a lot life is suffering we
suffer because we desire things
all right
and if you desire things [ __ ] it'll
make you you're going to be disappointed
with them and [ __ ] it'll in in it'll
[ __ ] make your suffering greater so
the best thing you should do is stop
desiring things
and then you won't suffer over them so
in other words kind of like an
enlightened detachment
and that's really kind of what that
scene was about is that yeah [ __ ] sucks
and then we die but that doesn't mean
that you shouldn't live your life yes
you know what i mean you should cut
that's part of the lessons of life
because we're temporary everything's
temporary everything's transient
and once you're good with that that's
all right and that is eventually
resolved in the series i think more with
miyagi although i think miyagi
accepted what had happened more and more
but he just kind of lamented over it you
know but i had to see the other
installments again
to make sure but
in general from what i remember the
series is that it made philosophical
sense
rob says the thing about part three that
didn't work was how daniel was so scared
of mike barnes when he just kicked the
ass of chosen a person with lifelong
knowledge of karate yeah that's right
like i said we watched all three of them
like a couple years back but we just
watched the first one again it's weird
because the only thing
that i had forgotten
was that
the end of part one i was just kind of
like i thought it was super abrupt
because i was like oh i thought there
was a scene
where mr miyagi like goes out to the
parking lot and then crease is being a
douche hat and he has to like kick
creases ass like out in the parking lot
but then um i think that that scene was
originally supposed to be at the end of
the first one if i'm not mistaken but it
actually is the beginning of the second
one so i was kind of like confused i was
like oh it just ended like i thought
there was another scene but yeah yeah
but that was actually like the first i
remember
really
thinking that one the first movie was
[ __ ] great and i remember really
liking two but i remember thinking that
three was okay but it had problems and
one of the problems that i kind of
remember sticking with me is that he
goes to okinawa and when they get to
okinawa it's an okinawa that never
really existed it's kind of like a theme
park taking place a hundred years ago it
does not look like a modern country
and welcome to medieval okanagan
it's like it doesn't look like that hold
on this is kind of like uh kind of like
a middle-class or working-class
fantasy conception of what you would
think an eastern country would be that's
not what okinawa would look like in the
80s
no maybe in the [ __ ] 1880s but not in
the 80s
[Laughter]
but they just tried to make it look real
real it's not like something real
foreign and exotic like something out of
national geographic
and no you would have went to okinawa
and saw mcdonald's and burger king well
yeah yeah and new wave nightclubs
and [ __ ] like that yeah yeah it's just
like a regular ass just like anything
else that's like yeah that was kind of
funny but yeah somebody brought up that
um pat morita was known for being uh
arnold on happy days yeah and that's
like initially why
they didn't want him like he did come in
to read um and he was kind of known for
being arnold on happy days and he was
also known as the stand-up comedian
um and they were like yeah we don't
really want that they wanted um
that guy uh what's his name tashio
mafune i think is his name he was in
like seven samurai and all that he's in
red son too uh yeah and they were like
we wanted that guy because he was kind
of like more
yeah and stuff like that but
uh in a way i'm like really glad that
they picked pat morita because what he
had to do like he came in and just
talked to his regular voice i think i
mentioned this the other day he does not
talk like he talks like mr maybe no he's
a california guy he's from california um
so he just talks like like a person from
california so uh but when he came in and
they didn't want him they said no you're
kind of known for being a funny guy we
don't really want that um so he came
back in and he started talking like his
uncle
uh and then they were kind of like oh
okay baby but i'm just really glad they
did that because
the chemistry between him and ralph
macchio
was really really good it just seemed
like a lot of the scenes of them
where they were just kind of like
playing off one another and they just
seemed so genuine yeah they i mean they
seemed like they were really like
friends like in real life and i just
thought that was really cool machio was
uh perfectly cast
oh yeah um
what they were looking for was a guy who
was a total whip but yeah like they said
yeah
had a chip on his shoulder
to make it plausible that he would seek
training and seek to beat dudes asses
that were picking on him
most wimps won't do it they'll just run
but they they [ __ ] did it right he
was he came from new york i think wasn't
it uh the character
i think it was jersey jerry seriously
yeah he came from jersey moves to
california
and uh some guys that rode dirt bikes he
went to high school with
back and started picking on him um
a lot of it had to do with the girl that
he was
had eyes for in the movie and really you
look at him a total mis mismatch i mean
me and jenny were astounded when we saw
her like man there's no [ __ ] way that
girl
and the the guys who uh directed the
movie said that they wanted that they
were it was just not plausible dudes
that looked like that didn't get girls
like that in high school
first of all she looks like she's ready
for her [ __ ] debut in a porn movie
she looks like [ __ ] ginger lid or
something he looks like a child
standing next to her even though like i
said they were probably about this
they're about to say i think they were
probably 18 19. but he looks like a
child he looks like a 14 year old yeah
and then when you see her
standing next to the [ __ ] lead bully
what was his name uh billy johnny
lawrence johnny johnny yeah you see him
standing next to him zapka is that
actor's name yeah you go oh that's
plausible
you know she'd be going out with that
guy but not not a [ __ ] ralph macchi
yeah because he was like twice ralph
machias yeah
and also they said he didn't know karate
he had to learn it for the movie but he
was a wrestler right so that's where
yeah he had done wrestling and the the
the director was like
they wanted a [ __ ]
they wanted you to go to look at them
standing side by side macho and that
girl go no way
yeah well i mean it's aspirational in
some ways because it's like an underdog
story and so you know people are going
to see themselves in it the director
said it was like looking at strawberry
shortcake next to a cannoli that's what
he said yeah that's what he said yeah
because we watched like a lot of the um
the extra stuff on this we're actually
like really entertaining well the thing
about like the screenplay for this was
actually written by uh robert mark
cayman who also wrote under siege uh the
fifth element taken like he's written a
whole bunch of stuff and this movie was
actually partially based on his own life
uh when he was a kid in 1964
uh he got his ass beat by a whole bunch
of bullies
and so he went and took martial arts and
he ended up taking martial arts for like
20 something years or something like
that um so it was kind of like so he
wrote about his experiences oh and the
first
martial arts school he went to
had a teacher that was very much like
crease where he was just kind of like
we're gonna kick everyone's ass and he
was just like he didn't really like it
so then he ended up going to another guy
who was whose name was actually miyagi
so the character is like named after a
real dude
but he was like so the second guy was a
lot more cool a lot more balanced and
stuff and he learned a lot more from
that guy but i just thought that and
there was like another i think the
producer too had come up with like this
article
about like a kid and they had a single
mom and like they got their ass beat by
bullies and then they learned martial
arts and got revenge and stuff like that
so he like combined the two things this
was also i didn't even realize but this
was directed by the same guy that
directed rocky
okay john ableton ableton appleton it's
a masterpiece movie of its of its genre
yeah i mean it's a sports movie for sure
but it's just kind of like it's also a
teen romance yeah underdog story uh it's
got a lot of good humor it's got eastern
philosophy in it or at least it's
simulating eastern philosophy it it fits
a lot of what you'd find in eastern
philosophies
um
it honors fighting traditions of karate
so it's not making a joke out of it it
does
it is a little bit deceptive about what
those disciplines could actually teach
you what they don't teach you but that's
okay it's it's an entertainment movie
it's
you're just not gonna take a person
who's not a fighter and turn them into a
fighter good enough to beat real
fighters asses it's not gonna happen all
right it just
mma proved that
okay it's not magic but that and that's
we'll talk about that later if we have
to but anyway it's it's a good
it's a good movie with a lot of little
life lessons in it i want to see the
second movie again see
because i don't remember exactly what
happened to it one of the things i did
like
about this movie is that in the end
they show
they show the the the reality that
morality is transient
everyone kind of exists in a state of
moral ambiguity
in the very end the bad
guys have earned respect
for john uh
like uh for for dan for daniel because
he's actually fighting
and their sensei tells them to do
illegal moves
to win the fight just in the name of
vengeance
even at
at their own sacrifice inside the damn
yeah because they'll get disciplined
so in the final scene when when when
danny [ __ ] knocks out
[ __ ] um johnny johnny yeah
he everybody everybody's kind of
cheering him on johnny gets up and says
you were right man you're you're a good
dude you're a good dude yeah and then
like the movie just and then the movie
ants because the thing about johnny and
the other cobra kai kids
were that they were jerks yeah but
because crease was so much of a bigger
jerk yeah they were just kind of like
bro
like
well it back a little bit and like i
said it's also one they still had some
honor when they were like we want to win
it was fairly honorable and we don't we
want we don't want to win fairly and
we're going to get disqualified if we do
what you say so that's
stupid so the guy that they're looking
up to is is telling them to dishonor
themselves yeah in the name of
vengeance which wasn't and because it's
honorable they wouldn't have won they
wouldn't have won they weren't gonna win
it was just gonna they were gonna get
themselves disqualified by doing it and
it's just like that was against the
spirit of what their mars what their
discipline was about
so
their instructors telling them to betray
the discipline
so that's when they're like no no if you
have to cheat to win in this discipline
then
no we don't want to do it so
so so what it is that kind of gives an
ultimate victory a victory better than
just winning because he converts the
enemy to the front into the friend
and that's that's the ultimate victory
it's better than killing the enemy it's
when you convert the enemy
yeah that's very eastern
i thought it was funny i can't remember
what happened in the second one because
is johnny lawrence in the second one too
or no no he's not in it okay i don't
think he's in it because if you haven't
seen the series this recent series cobra
kai yeah uh which is has all this all
the characters from the movie like
pretty much everybody came back that was
still alive
um but they still have like this beef
like all this all these years later
plausible it is but it's it's great it
works that's right yeah well because
cobra kai
they knew what made the original movie
so appealing yeah um you know so it is
very heartfelt it is very genuine and it
does take itself seriously it's not
really winking at it but it is but like
in a in a lighthearted like fun yeah
warm kind of way not like in a oh isn't
this ridiculous
and and the johnny character is a lot
more interesting than the daniel
character in some ways in a lot of ways
so johnny kind of carries the series
he's he's a lot more interesting guy
he's a little more conflicted
and
funnier in a way
because it turns out daniel ends up just
being kind of like a regular car guy and
you know he's not real he didn't change
all that much really but um
you know
i was looking johnny did
that's my favorite thing about the first
season of cobra kai is that johnny he
just ended up being well like a lot of
people that were like peaked in high
school type yeah in high school where he
just like it so this many years later
like he's still driving at 80s camaro
and listening to brock and it's like he
lives in this scuzzy apartment with like
empty beer cans everybody doesn't use
social media because he doesn't know how
to like use facebook
and uh he tries to re-open up code
recovery that's hysterical it's good
though but he's like he's such a good
character he becomes the hero of the of
that it if you ask me he becomes a hero
of the series
yeah
you're rooting for him too yeah which uh
which i always like that because it goes
it goes back to like it says in certain
ways i don't see moral relative
moral relativism or moral ambiguity it's
just there's different moral viewpoints
uh he he's a good dude though you know
he's yeah he's not a bad dad he learned
his lesson back in that
in that championship uh
uh that there were his since they
[ __ ] told him to betray the [ __ ]
honor of the [ __ ] sport you know then
he was like oh i can't look up to guys
like this
you know you should win winning at all
costs no not necessarily no not a good
thing yeah that's yeah not within the
front i mean any kind of extreme like
right right yeah usually generally not
good right oh you know what's funny
stratox78 just said uh you know you're
getting old when you start checking out
daniel's mom you know what's funny
that is funny that you should say that
because when we were watching this movie
tom says to me
um he's like you know when i watched
this movie as a kid because it came out
in 1984. yeah we were kids you know what
i mean he's like i was thinking like
daniel's mom i was just like you know
she's an old woman she's like someone's
mom yeah but he's like looking at her
now it's like she's totally not old
she's actually like pretty cute yeah
she's cute
[Laughter]
oh my that's like yeah that's like
really funny yeah you said that a lot to
me like uh movies that you saw when you
were a kid and yeah go back and look at
them yeah people that played like the
parents and stuff they seemed old to you
like back then but like when you see it
now you're like oh my god she's like 35.
she's like 30 yeah or something like
that
rob says also in cobra kai johnny was a
drunk for like 20 years yeah well daniel
had been actively training for 30 years
yeah so daniel's level of karate should
be much higher than johnny yeah i mean
the thing about it is that johnny is
much bigger and has like a lot more
weight on him you know what what killed
me about cobra kai like when i first
started watching the first season of it
was just kind of like not only one that
they got every [ __ ] back from like
from the movies it was still alive but
they all look great yep
they don't really look all that
different like you know 30 [ __ ] years
later however long it's been yeah dude
to play johnny looks fantastic i mean
they all look they still look really
good yeah rob macho still looks pretty
young you know he's put on some weight
in terms of like good weight not bad
weight yeah i mean he's big and like he
was like
he's filled out but he's filled out when
he was a kid he was just [ __ ]
ridiculously well i mean yeah he was
just scrawny when he was a kid but like
when yeah when he got older he filled
out like so he looks like an adult but
his face he still has that baby face
same thing with anthony michael hall you
think of him like from weird science but
when you see him when he was in his 40s
and when he was in his late 40s in
[ __ ] uh the dead zone nah man that's
a [ __ ] totally different dude i don't
know what cycle he hit but he was big
well like i said he first started
looking like that the first time i saw
him looking like that was in um edward
scissorhands never scissor hands he got
pretty he's he was gone for a few years
and then he came back and i was like
holy [ __ ] yeah like recognize him i put
him in the honk carrot uh yeah he got
totally hot yeah well it was just like
funny because he was playing like all
these like pencil next granny geeks like
in movies in the 80s then a few years
later he turns out and then he's like a
football jock yeah like a football job
you know what i mean which i thought
that was like super funny yeah yeah
slasher fred just brought up anthony
michael hall but yeah the thing of okay
so the thing about karate kid i mean
this came out i mean 1984 man that was a
[ __ ] great year for movies so many
good [ __ ] movies came out that year
including ghostbusters which was
probably my favorite when they came out
that year
but the thing about karate kid was that
i didn't see it in the theater
um i saw it on cable
but it wasn't one i saw it a few times
but it wasn't one that i watched like a
zillion times like maybe like the john
hughes movies or something like that i
mean back in the 80s i probably watched
like pretty in pink like 400 times and
breakfast club like 400 times and [ __ ]
like that but for whatever reason the
karate kid i only saw like a cup like a
handful of times and i liked it but it
didn't like resonate with me the same
way
but watching it now i think i have like
a lot more
appreciation for it i think like of you
know where it's coming from yeah maybe i
don't know if it was because it was more
like a boy focus story or and like i so
i didn't so it didn't resonate with me
as much at the time i'm glad that it's a
boy focused story yeah
those those
back in those days which they needed to
bring it back
they
the younger you are the more gendered
you are that just be truthful about it
man like when i was a little kid oh man
girl stuff oh you know it's just it's
cooties yeah it's everywhere you know
what i mean it's just and it's been that
way for since the dawn of man
and uh sometimes to get through the
thick skulls of [ __ ] young guys you
have to show them a movie that's
tailored to them they'll
and teach them
stories that really are focused on them
girls will watch it
yeah i watch
it yeah it's just that it doesn't really
hit the exact same centers of the brain
that it does
uh with young guys you know
i remember it you know like we were you
know in high school
which you could relate to a lot of what
was being said and like oh yeah
yeah yeah i'd do the same thing you know
that kind of [ __ ] you know [ __ ] it's
fantasy but you don't really
see how fantastical it is until you're
older but you you learn from it i mean
obviously it's got some like ridiculous
[ __ ] like i said it's you know it's
ridiculous to think that maybe like pat
morita could kick the asses of like five
or six teenagers at once you know it's
yeah it's not not just the whole i mean
the whole yeah i kind of feel like the
bullies too were kind of like going out
of their way like more
to pick on this one kid well there were
stereo which yeah which that was that
happened a lot in 80s movies and i'm not
saying that like people didn't get
bullied they did but usually it wasn't
this prolonged
like and there wasn't that much thought
put into it like if you happen to like
well yeah like if you happen to like if
they didn't like you and you happen to
wander across their oh let's kick that
person's ass you know then they would do
it but it wasn't so much like whether
they would have this like machiavellian
sort of like
playing like for doing all this stuff
and obviously shit's not decided by one
big like sports thing or anything but
like i said a lot of movies in the 80s
kind of revolved around that because
it's a you know it's a it's an easy
three-act structure we're building up to
the karate tournament or the prom or
whatever the [ __ ] you're kind of like
building up to one big thing at the end
where all where all of this stuff is
gonna happen and everything's gonna be
fixed or resolved or whatever so you
know so it very much like follows that
which is pretty much all sports movies
what they would do is they would make
guy ones and i wanted to say before i
change the subject on it is that as
ludicrous as this
fantastical as this movie is
in a way teenage boys are in that world
it does express it that's kind of the
way reality seems when you're when
you're a teenage boy
because a lot of that [ __ ] just seemed
normal to us in that story yeah i look
back in and out i go no that doesn't
that doesn't happen get out of me
but you don't think of it that way when
you're that age because you kind of have
everything is charmed and magical and
you know what i mean every day is a big
deal and it's just it does have that
you know
feeling to it of being kind of young and
dumb
and yeah well and i think that's exactly
why it works and why people
our age remember it so fondly and
probably why you know people that are
young nowadays can still relate to it
because those emotions are kind of like
universal now they had them they did the
same thing um
that targeted females and that would be
stuff like pretty and pink 16 candles uh
[ __ ] breakfast club you know what i
mean which although some of the john
hughes movies i would argue someone
crossed over yeah i mean breakfast club
i would argue is just more gender
neutral um because that wasn't really
that was unfocused on female
boys and girls yeah pretty in pink
slightly more female focused uh you know
some kind of wonderful maybe more
female-focused but he did other movies
like ferris bueller's day off and stuff
like that that were more neutral it was
just kind of like even though that was
mostly based on a male character but
there was also like you know his
girlfriend and the other so i feel like
that was a little bit more yeah
universal but it was good writing though
and good marketing so anybody could
watch it and get something out of it and
same thing like i said even though the
karate kid wasn't like my favorite
in the 80s i did like it yeah and
watching it now i have a lot more
appreciation for it yeah than maybe i
did at the time i think some of the
stuff that is lost in you with from the
younger generations of today what would
be lost culturally is that in the 80s
karate and martial arts you know like
taekwondo and jiu jitsu was almost
basically a subject about paranormal
people weren't really sure what was
possible what wasn't possible
you had
you didn't have mass media you didn't
have youtube you didn't have
a bunch of information on martial arts
you would just see these crazy
kung fu flicks from china going way back
to this in in way back to the 60s and
70s bruce lee doing these fantastic
feats
and then all these legends about what is
possible and what isn't you know what is
actually possible with
martial arts
it's almost kind of like magic is what
they're talking about doing the
impossible
yeah and they're throwing your cheeks
yeah it's she balls and [ __ ]
you're like well only like a 12 degree
black belt master and bushido can do
that [ __ ] you know and we did another if
you want to know more about it then we
did another show called bullshitto it's
on it's it's it's you just search for
the show
um there's a lot of [ __ ] in martial
arts but there was no way to check back
then
and there were a lot of martial arts
frauds that people thought really
happened
and uh in the 80s they were came out
martial arts magazines like [ __ ]
black belt magazine and
then martial arts girls you know like
cynthia rothrock jumps in and then
there's movies with her you know oh man
i watched a movie
i can't remember what it was called but
it was on roof tracks oh my god that
[ __ ] was terrible yeah terrible
and then there's like
martial arts video games like [ __ ] i
think one of them was called i think one
of them was called kung fu no no what
was the one
it was the one the two karate guys he'd
go fight and then i don't remember
mortal kombat no no no what's that
mortal kombat
just two guys a red guy and a white guy
with a with a judge in the middle it was
real crude
it was before i don't remember that one
it was it was before um
street fighter and mortal kombat
some of you guys probably remember which
one it is but i remember that very first
uh kung fu game that blew our minds and
then
shinobi came out we were playing the
[ __ ] out of shinobi
and it's showing all kinds of [ __ ]
magical mystical [ __ ] happening so
you weren't really sure what what you
know
there was no there's magical asians yeah
[ __ ] could fly they showed it
in the [ __ ] movies you know i saw
crouching tiger hitting dragon
and then she was much later we knew his
[ __ ] by then
but um
trying to think trying to think trying
to put it into a [ __ ] good context
we
we
i mean
they could kind of fool you back then
there was no way to double check
well especially if you're a dumb
teenager especially if you're a teenager
you're like well maybe maybe that could
happen and there was there was no mma
all right we didn't even have ultimate
fighting yet
and some of the things that they would
talk about like yeah they're you know
bruce lee wanted a fighting with no
[ __ ] rules you know what i mean where
where it's just fighting however you
want bare-knuckled you know like oh man
cage fighting basically like was that
legal man that's against the law isn't
it yeah dudes can get killed in that
like well you know dudes are getting
killed in boxing too
dudes were getting killed in football
yep dudes are getting most dudes are
getting killed and [ __ ] car
motorcycle racing
uh yeah big time so
yeah why couldn't you go in there just
[ __ ] fight you know beat each other
up into submission
but i remember when [ __ ] ultimate
fighting first appeared
people were like that was like almost
like something slightly criminal they
were thinking man like something what
the hell
well in the martial arts world before
all that [ __ ] happened in the martial
arts [ __ ] dojo
mall dojo world you know where there's
all these [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh legends that you could go off
to the far east and fight in these
competitions you know these and that
they actually it was all [ __ ] made
up by a [ __ ] old what's his name
who's that [ __ ] frank ducks ducks
yeah frank ducks made that [ __ ] up and
then they made a movie about that that
had um
um
jean-claude john valencia what was that
what was that what was it called blood
sport blood sport see jenny's memory is
good i'm not drunk when i'm drunk my
memory is even better but uh
[Laughter]
bloodsport is basically
what bruce lee was talking about
well that [ __ ] never really happened
what happened was this [ __ ]
mma
which that's that and none of those damn
kung fu masters made it through the mma
no
all of a sudden they didn't want to
fight when they were stuff like that
again now in china
they got some they got an mma fighter
you can see this [ __ ] you can see the
[ __ ] on youtube they got a good mma
fighter there and he challenged he says
he he was on
chinese youtube
telling him that nah man marshall kung
fu gong foo and all this he goes that's
all [ __ ] i'll challenge any damn
master fight me and you i'll [ __ ] you up
basically well they had some dude in his
60s so he basically tried to pray his
way in there and throw chee balls and
that dude beats the [ __ ] out of him in
front of a [ __ ] crowd and then all of
china [ __ ] attacked that guy he
almost made him [ __ ] commit suicide
because you have shamed china china's
martial arts and he goes yeah but it's
right it's fake
some people don't want to hear the truth
but uh
yeah i didn't realize that but yeah
china china still believes the hype
or they want to believe the hype
but the ultimate martial art if that's
what you want to call it is mma
if it doesn't work in mma it doesn't
work
and ultimately none of this karate kung
fu stuff works
not against the train fighter not again
those train fighters are an amma
stardog 78 said cynthia rothrock should
have been included in the expendables
she got snubbed
yeah yeah that's right i wonder why they
didn't know that maybe she didn't want
to do it
i don't know [ __ ] once his name
[ __ ] uh seagal didn't want to go he
was afraid they'd make fun of him
because they were
well they were going to make fun of us
yeah here comes steven skull waddling
yeah
[ __ ] stunt double just to sit down
gotta go upstairs where's my stunt
double
dude so fat
he just they just show him from the
[ __ ] chin up and then they got
somebody dubbing him
yeah that's so weird what was that what
is that about he can't even like he
can't be bothered to like talk in his
own movies anymore he can't be in his
own movies i can argue why don't they
just have a still photo of him and put
it in front of the camera that he
doesn't even have to show up
and they just have somebody talking like
in voiceover whenever it's walking
around it could just be somebody liking
a [ __ ] ninja outfit or some [ __ ] he
can't be in his own movies
i mean at this point you might as well
just put a picture of them there just
put a picture yeah force to go
although i saw something [ __ ]
recently i saw some recent videos
something he was doing on youtube and he
was he was being funny he was kind of
laughing at himself so maybe he's really
maybe he learned yeah i think he was
kind of i would have thought that he was
kind of lampooning himself too old to
like get past that yeah i think he i
think he realized that that the jig was
up
like dude everyone's laughing at you
maybe if you were like
in on the joke everyone would laugh with
you
but you know i guess i was like
oh it is paint on hair and [ __ ] yeah and
he's uh
although i'll tell you what this is
totally off topic but the steven seagal
merchandise
like old merchandise like old posters
where he was going to go to some event
it's like xeroxed it's worth a lot of
money
they have dudes that will [ __ ]
collect steven seagal stuff i think it's
i think it's like uh irony
but they still buy it
well remember that guy that's i can't
remember what his name is but he's on uh
cinemassacre sometimes yeah and that
dude
is like a huge steven seagal fan i think
ironically but
kind of not
like he has every single steven seagal
movie he has like all of this
collectible stuff he even bought like
the shitty energy drinks that he did
drinks right yeah like off of ebay
experience the asian experience that's
so there was two other ones but the but
the titles the names of them weren't as
funny as asian experience
as much as that bag on cigar he did have
some good movies some of them were good
yeah most of them weren't but he wasn't
even himself he wasn't even in the
karate kid so what are you talking about
it's martial arts i'm just saying it's
martial it's martial arts it's adjacent
but uh now this is a good movie and if
you guys haven't seen it i'd recommend
it i mean you know everybody i feel like
everybody should probably see the karate
kid it's one of those movies from the
80s
i mean it's iconic
and it's also one of those movies too
that even if you haven't seen it
then you've still kind of probably seen
it because there's so many so much of
the like lines from it everything like
that have like you know seeped into the
zeitgeist or whatever so
i mean the the first thing
you know when this stream started the
first thing somebody commented was wax
on wax off like i said if you say that
to somebody every single person on earth
probably uh or at least in the u.s and
in europe like know what that is like
know where that came from they're
talking about sunny chiba
sly was talking about studies i remember
that
um frank dux is full of [ __ ] of course
he was full of [ __ ] he's a pathological
liar
yeah yeah
uh danny goes face says karate is used
in uf ufc's it's definitely effective
but it's not the karate that would be
considered karate back in the 80s and
80s
karate of the 80s was highly formalized
this further you go backwards in time
the more formal and inflexible and
flexible it was uh that was the reason
why
um guys like uh well what's his name
entered the dragon but bruce lee bruce
lee was trying to
turn the it turned that thing into
something a little bit more flexible
and karate had no ground game you know
it had punches and kicks that was about
it
um
my stepbrother was a [ __ ] bad asset
uh taekwondo would win all the champions
of the tournaments with the size and
tonfaw and do all this he could just
stand in one spot and reach his [ __ ]
right leg up with his toe and just touch
the touch the ceiling and stand there
and he was doing that in in
high school
and he was like the best one out of
their whole [ __ ] dojo name of the you
know billy
billy dumont is his name
and uh he got in a fight one time
granthars was probably there he got in a
fight at a high school football game and
beat up about four or five dudes from
another school that was woodhaven and
then they all ran off in their cars
but if you ever but if you saw the fight
he didn't use any taekwondo and he just
[ __ ] whipped their asses because he
was real good at punching and kicking
people in the face
you could stand there and talk to him
like you could be standing there talking
to him and he could kick you in your jaw
and knock you out
but there wasn't any [ __ ] forms or
anything it was like something you'd see
in a uf ufc fighter
but had he done that in some of those
little kara taekwondo matches they would
have disqualified him so no you did the
form wasn't quite right and this and
that the judges wouldn't have liked it
so what worked in those tournaments
wasn't what actually you did in a fight
well i think that's kind of true of
anything well and i think they kind of
go into that a little bit in this movie
as well because i mean you know daniel
he doesn't you know mr miyagi doesn't
start teaching him karate as he makes
him like wash his cars and paint his
fences and all this other kind of stuff
because he's just trying to teach him
muscle memory yeah and so when you're
doing the [ __ ] at a tournament yeah
there's rules and you have to do [ __ ]
like that but
i think it's good because it teaches you
like i said muscle memory if you're in
you know if you're in that kind of thing
at least you'll sort of like if you're
in a real fight at least you'll kind of
have some idea of
of what to do you know in the 70s and
the 80s in that period a lot of the
martial arts that was respected and like
official
was on par with chinese dance theater
which it was very similar i think it's
where a lot of it came from
what was it the hong kong theater
which is like um they would dance and
costumes and do
gong foo but it was more of a dance
same thing with kaipuera brazilian
caipuera
it's it's it's dance but it's also kind
of like a martial art but you know
[ __ ] gracie who's brazilian
uses mma you know you're not gonna be
able to use capoeira on him
um
it's just uh
you know
you're just trying to label things as
karate or as kung fu or this it's just
[ __ ] fighting you know and to be able
to put the labels on it there has to be
a visual style
and that was the thing about
70s
martial arts it was very stylish it had
to be had to look like something stylish
or they didn't like it you say well
that's not
that's not karate that's or that's not
kung fu that's just fighting you you got
a kung fu fight
you know what i mean
so
because at the tournaments there were
judges yeah so
mma is not really like that it's just
fighting
yeah i mean i feel like it was going to
go that way yeah i mean right because
that's what people want to see you know
they just want to see who wins they
don't they don't want to like they don't
care about the style of it too much yeah
they're just like hey we just want to
see the [ __ ] out of each other and
karate and karate and because of that
karate and taekwondo and kung fu they
had no ground game they couldn't wrestle
all right so
some people were going like well what
about bruce lee and this and that bruce
lee probably got what could go to mma
without any [ __ ] bruce lee in his prime
if he stepped into an mma arena would
get his ass whipped
now
he could retrain
put another 20 pounds on him
and teach him how to wrestle
just give him some the ability to focus
on more on some ground game and
bruce lee would have done well
he was good but he was more of an actor
you know
he he wanted to fight but
it would cost him money if he got hurt
he wouldn't be able to film
yeah
yeah i mean i believe bruce lee would
have been a good mma fighter yeah i mean
[ __ ] he was in excellent shape yeah
but he would have to have [ __ ]
trained for it and and and accepted and
uh learned to adapt to uh
uh something outside of what would
normally be called martial arts and be
able to throw in wrestling and grappling
and [ __ ] like that with it and then he
would have been good
in his weight class
danny rowling's talking about elizabeth
shu and leaving las vegas leaving las
vegas
this was actually i didn't realize but
this was actually her first movie her
first uh and uh actually it was william
zabka's first movie too the guy that
played johnny lawrence yeah and ralph
macchio he was in the outsiders before
this but this was like his first main
role this was like the role that like
made him a mega star that where he was
on like the cover of teen beat and [ __ ]
like that the guy who became the guy who
plays johnny what's his name again
william zapko yeah that guy could be
that guy's a credible actor
yeah like i said this was his first
movie so and he was actually like pre he
was brett and he was great in this well
what i'm saying is after the tv series
you know i mean that he could go on to
do whatever he wanted yeah i think i
think because people like that guy
i don't know like i don't i don't
remember seeing him in a lot of stuff i
don't think he did a lot of stuff yeah
after that i mean until cobra kai yeah
came out like i'm sure he was in other
stuff i just didn't really remember i
just didn't remember it or i didn't see
it yeah you know what's funny i was
looking at um i was looking at the
wikipedia page about this movie earlier
and it said um that you know who they
wanted for the role of johnny the bully
crisp and glover
that wouldn't work
he would have been funny i'm gonna weird
you to death
i don't know it might have well i don't
know
yeah he is the thing about crispin
glover is that
i mean he gives off like crazy person
energy so that kind of maybe has its own
but yeah i don't really see chrisman
glover like bullying somebody like i
said when i think of a bully i usually
think of somebody like william zabka
like a big like a jock type yeah because
that's usually what was happening like
when i was in high school so i kind of
feel like that's
more so i'm kind of glad that they that
they
went that direction
but yeah
yeah but yeah i think elizabeth shu the
only thing she'd done before this was
like some bit like a burger king
commercial or something like that yeah i
think that's where they saw her first
but yeah um
let's see so are we we've opted but yeah
we're pretty much i'm pretty much good
yeah we're good all right so i guess
we'll wrap it up for the weekend
and uh we'll come back tomorrow and talk
about
we're going to talk about
the jack reacher movie yeah
the tom cruise one it was good i didn't
realize uh until i started like
researching that
um i mean i knew it was based on lee
child's books because i think i read a
couple of them like a long time ago but
i didn't realize that only a few months
ago on i guess it's on amazon prime they
actually made a series like a jack
creature series
that's based on because there's been
like a [ __ ] ton of the books right and
uh yeah there was actually when they
when the movies came out with tom cruise
there was kind of like a controversy but
i'll get into that like tomorrow but
yeah so tomorrow we'll be talking about
jack reacher if you haven't seen jaguars
you can check it out it's free on amazon
if you have an amazon prime yeah it's
basically i don't know about the second
one tom cruise has batman basically yeah
without the without the suit
it's good though
it's just a straight up movie it's
nothing really you know it's nothing
outlandish or anything it's just like a
movie that tom cruise would be in
and he just tried he just [ __ ] tom
cruises the [ __ ] out of it
you know but it's pretty good as he does
yeah as he does but it's pretty good
pretty good i like it starbucks 78 said
lol crisp and glover almost took off
david letterman's head with a snip kick
i remember that
didn't let me kick his ass off the ship
and i would punch i would kick kick i
don't know what was that dude i want
something
i don't i don't know if he's on
something or if he's just weird
yeah i mean he's just weird i love
christmas
i still love uh one of my favorite
movies of his is actually bartleby yeah
if you guys have seen that danny rowling
said uh any redhead nowadays is
considered the bully in cinema which is
[ __ ] up for gingers is that what
they're doing now they're making friends
please i kind of feel like back in the
day it was like blonde jocks were always
the bullies not always but usually
or like i don't know just like big tough
guy or
i was i don't know why i thought of this
but i was thinking of christine
the movie christine from 1983. where the
bullies were just kind of those vaguely
sweat hog looking guys or like those old
like burnout type dudes with like with
the long ratty hair that kind of looked
like the ramones or something they kind
of looked like that camp guy said he he
said he found a youtube podcast had btk
with his self taking bondage photos took
himself all tied up he never seen him
before you never seen those man we've
seen those he got down into the damn
[ __ ] grave just dug that grave with
the [ __ ] had the damn girl mask on
and he's [ __ ] in his lingerie all
tied up with something around his neck
and what's up dennis dennis was a
[ __ ] freak man
like and you know if he was sexy look
he was sexy if if that's what you're
into fine but don't be a serial killer
like as long as you're not serial
killing as long as you're not killing
anybody yeah you can take whatever
pictures of yourself you know whatever
get your rocks out however have rocks
off everyone but he was cross-dressing
yeah which you know trying to
dressing up like the girls he was
killing
well not quite because he was not not
really uh looking like he thought he was
i guess he was trying he had a good
imagination yeah he was tried to
empathize or something
i don't know i don't know if i'd use
that word but
i don't know he was trying to take their
place
see what it felt yeah it was like a
really weird yeah
i know i've brought this up before but
sophie sent me a book a long time ago
called i think it's called confessions
or conversations with a killer or
something like that but it's about btk
and it's all like his letters like
correspondence that he wrote with this
journalist i like after he was in prison
that dude's thought processes are
[ __ ]
bizarre yeah holy [ __ ] i mean which i
guess stands to reason because he's a
serial killer what did you expect well
no but i mean i've read some like [ __ ]
about some serial killers i mean they
sound like dirt bags but they still
sound like i don't know what to say like
relatable but like the emotions seem
like human emotions like the btk
letters i was just kind of like what the
[ __ ] is this dude's deal man it's just
like he's in fantasy
yeah he just comes up with that he had
all these [ __ ] he had a very very
elaborate like fantasy life and it was
just like really alarming i guess that's
why uh but yeah so tomorrow we'll be
back uh same time same channel uh
talking about the first jack reacher
movie so hopefully you guys will
come and see us for that uh so until
then have a good rest of your weekend
and we will see you guys again tomorrow